hey guys you know what I really hate
about myself everything that too but I
am my own worst critic
sometimes I critique things before
there's even anything to critique it's
horrible what are you talking about it's
blank I've gotten into this terrible
habit of judging what I'm doing while
I'm doing it and as a result I end up
not even doing anything okay so I'm
ready to start on my new book sighted
all right the opening sentence and I
hate it nothing the stifles your
creativity more than that asshole in
your head who's telling you that what
you haven't even done yet sucks and it's
not just creatively like I've noticed
I'm starting to do it socially as well
the skirt screams I'm a pretentious
artist who thinks her art has some
socio-political deep hidden meaning this
beret screams that I think I'm super
cool and should be smoking a cigarette
and eating up again in France or
something you know what maybe I should
just go naked yeah I'll just go naked
and it's so frustrating because I feel
like the fear of judgment and the
pressure to do things right or make
things good has kind of made me hesitant
you know there's that fear of like oh
like I remember I was trying to start a
book for so long and I kept like
freaking out about the opening sentence
so I went back through like my book
collection and like read the opening
sentence of all these different books
like how am I gonna return it as that
and then like I a ganache for like half
an hour like it should be in first
person
should it be in third person is this so
stupid so just do it just do it step
over analyzing and overthinking it and
putting this immense amount of pressure
from absolutely nowhere but my head and
it's just a terrible habit I've gotten
into and I don't know if you guys suffer
from this as well but I feel like we all
tend to be our own worst critics and I'm
frankly quite sick of mine because you
know everyone in your life and the whole
world essentially it's gonna tell you
you suck it's gonna tell you you can't
do this you can't do that why even try
why even bother
and why do we need to hear that from
ourselves
hey Sookie mix up stir just a quick fYI
what you're writing right now is gonna
totally suck donkey balls oh really
say um did I ever tell you about what
happened to the inner troll stay
awesome Gotham